The turmoil in Caracas has subsided for now.
But burned-out vehicles serve as a reminder
of what happened here the day before.
Thousands took to the streets to demonstrate
against the government. More than two dozen
protesters were killed. Opposition leader
Juan Guaido declared himself caretaker president
and vowed to end what he called "a dictatorship",
before disappearing to an unknown location.
While many western countries agree with Guaido,
Maduro's own international allies have thrown
their weight behind his socialist government,
with Maduro acknowledging the backing of Russian
president Vladimir Putin.
"Russia gives its full support to the legitimate
and constitutional government that I preside
over, its full support for peace and the integrity
and sovereignty of Venezuela. Putin told me:
'President Maduro, you can count on the unwavering
support of Russia.' And now, more than ever,
we will be working on bilateral projects to
further develop Venezuela."
On the other side, the United States seeks
to increase pressure on Maduro by starving
his regime of funds.
What we're focusing on today is disconnecting
the illegitimate Maduro regime from the sources
of its revenues. We think consistent with
our recognition of Juan Guaido as the constitutional
interim president of Venezuela, that those
revenues should go to the legitimate government.
Washington ordered some of its diplomatic
staff to leave Caracas, but refused to comply
with a full expulsion as ordered by Maduro.
Meanwhile, Maduro has been reaffirmed by both
the Supreme Court and the military. But Guaido
didn't shy from commenting on Maduro's future
in a televised interview from an undisclosed
location.
Are you also offering amnesty to Nicolas Maduro?
That would have to be looked at.He is
also a public employee. Unfortunately, he
is a dictator and responsible for yesterday's
victims.
Venezuelans on both sides now await Guaido's
next move.